ein corona virus bringt nicht so schnell
aus der fassung kein impfstoff und erst
recht kein gesundheitsminister wann
immer man die kleinen schurken stellen
linie sind sie längst über alle berge in
der nächsten sucht variante und eine
solche ist in deutschland wieder auf dem
vormarsch die a5 genannt und könnte uns
sommer und herbst versauen
steigende kundenzahlen zurück zu den
maßnahmen jetzt in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
im studio linda teuteberg ist bei uns
mitglied im fdp-bundesvorstand
und mitglied im bundestag und dort im
innenausschuss aktiv
matthias mir das ist hier
stellvertretende gesundheitspolitische
sprecher der spd-bundestagsfraktion und
folglich mitglied des
gesundheitsausschusses
im bundestag
anna schneider ist chefreporterin
freiheit der weltgruppe und professor
timm ulrichs epidemiologe und
infektiologe an der akad hochschule für
humanwissenschaften in berlin
besorgniserregend ist die situation im
moment eigentlich man spricht von einer
sommer bälle die inzidenz steigen die
sich dann möglicherweise auch noch auf
die herbst und winter welle draufsetzt
beziehungsweise die grundlage bildet
dann dafür dass eine eine weitere welle
im herbst zu erwarten ist und die dann
auch noch mit höheren zahlen weiter
gehen wird das hatten wir bisher noch
nicht allerdings hatten wir früher in
den beiden saison davor ja auch
virusvarianten die etwas mehr klinische
schärfere klinische verläufe gemacht
haben oder auch eine höhere todesrate
hatten aber trotzdem sollte man das
nicht auf die leichte schulter nehmen
also wenn sie so fragen ja das ist ernst
zu nehmen und wir sollten uns auch
entsprechend und rechtzeitig vorbereiten
wenn man die krone politik der
bundesregierung ansieht wie
voreilig oder wie vorausschauend ist sie
eigentlich sie ist vorausschauend ich
greife gerne mal ihrer anmoderation auf
dass ein virus nichts aus der fassung
bringen ich finde auch uns sollte nichts
aus so sehr aus der fassung bringen dass
wir nicht mehr unsere verfassung waren
sondern wir wollen und das tun wir uns
besonnen und evidenzbasiert auf diesen
herbst vorbereiten das tun wir dafür
nehmen wir die erkenntnisse ernst die
uns der expertenrat mit geben wird und
dann gibt es auch zwei sitzungswochen in
denen ein ganz geordnetes
gesetzgebungsverfahren
stattfinden kann im september und das
werden wir tun das notwendige tun aber
eben auch genau darauf achten welche
maßnahmen sind sinnvoll und nicht auf
vorrat auf dieses geordnete verfahren da
sind wir ganz gespannt
ist der gesundheitsminister ihre partei
von karl lauterbach sagte bis auf
nuancen
dass sich die ampel über die zu
treffenden corona maßnahmen einig das
sagt ja foto rehberg jetzt auch kritiker
dieser politik der regierung sprechen
von einer art sommerschlaf außerdem ist
dann im herbst ein böses erwachen
gelangen wir eigentlich aus der
vergangenheit natürlich lernen wir und
ich kann nur bestätigen was meine
kollegin fort heute berg schon gesagt
hat wir haben einen plan und wir haben
einen professionellen arbeitsmodus und
das bedeutet dass wir uns faktenbasiert
dem herbst und auch jetzt natürlich dem
sommer zu nähern und deshalb hat unser
gesundheitsminister lauterbach einen
sieben punkte plan aufgestellt zudem wir
einigkeit in der ampel haben und wir
werden uns die nächsten wochen anschauen
was wir ergänzen wie wir das
infektionsschutzgesetz weiterentwickeln
und auch da kann ich nur auf meine
kollegin verweisen wir schauen uns das
gutachten des experten beirates an was
es schon gibt mit klaren empfehlung zu
verschiedenen szenarien und wir werden
es ergänzen um die erkenntnisse die wir
vom sachverständigenrat in der kommenden
woche bekommen dazu wird es nochmal ein
fazit geben wie die bisherigen maßnahmen
sich ausgewirkt haben und diese fakten
basis werden wir nutzen um unsere
strategie für den herbst weiter zu
entwickeln darauf komme ich gleich noch
mal zu sprechen verschneider wird uns
der freiheit sommer noch leid tun wenn
wir im herbst wieder maskiert in unseren
bau zurück griechen müssen wegen hoher
infektionszahlen zunächst mal möchte ich
kurz zeigen wie kann da vieles finde
dass die ampel hier ist es schön einige
sie kriegt das ja von außen zu das
mitsenden über so bleibt das auch aber
wenn man sich anschaut was da jetzt
passiert also ist wenn alles so wäre wie
sich meine anderen er sehr schön dass
jetzt abwarten was nächste woche
passiert wir folgen den
expertenempfehlungen und vor allem auch
dass die revolution ergibt und schauen
dann weiß ich welche maßnahmen sinnvoll
sind aber was er jetzt gerade passiert
ist schon was ganz anderes also wir
führen ja eigentlich dieselbe diskussion
wie sie vor zwei jahren geführt haben
hat jetzt schon irgendwie im sommer der
angst modus wird wieder lauter herr
lauterbach hat ja panik auch als zeit
nun vornehmen also ich krieg schon wieso
bauchweh wenn ich jetzt so waren diese
vier bundesländer sie jetzt vorpreschen
wenn herr kretschmann ein ernstes sagt
er will alles können auch
ausgangssperren also ich weiß nicht ob
er sich noch spürt um ehrlich zu sein
also in diesem sinne hoffe doch sehr
dass dann müssen was meine freiheit und
dass die ampel so arbeitet und nicht so
wie es gerade präsentiert das hatte ich
aber gefragt wird uns dieser freiheit
sommer noch leid tun wenn wir uns dann
maskiert wieder zurück wie kann eine
wahl frei zumal leid tun das glaub ich
wirklich nicht also jetzt moment glaube
ich und ich bin kein biologe aber kann
und muss man nicht mehr machen außer
vorsorge dafür zu treffen dass uns das
im herbst wenn eine größere welle kommt
oder eine variante die schlimmer ist
euch jetzt die letzte omikron variante
aber da geht es ja nicht in erster linie
um masken oder so das ist eine
scheindebatte da geht ja darum dass es
dass die variablen gruppen geschützt
werden dass das pflegepersonal da also
braucht und dass die galten als nicht
belastet werden und das ist alles nicht
was jetzt vor allem eben diese vier
bundesländer inklusive ein kretschmann
fordern gut auch die massen kommen auch
noch gleich zurück ulrichs die inzidenz
ziehen also das was pro 100.000
einwohnern an fällen auftritt und die
sogenannten die neue infektion jeden tag
die schnellen in die höhe knapp jetzt
unter 500 glaube ich
verantwortlich ist ja diese so genannte
variante b 5 die ist durchaus ansteckend
kann auch ein gefährlicher und verlauf
als die anderen varianten davor haben
sind die menschen zu sorglos geworden
nach denen die meisten corona
schutzmaßnahmen jetzt anfang mai
aufgehoben worden sind diese lockerung
hatten ja durchaus schon einen sinn weil
man nach lassen konnte mit diesen ganzen
maßnahmen angesichts der abebbenden
welle dazu vor das war schon in ordnung
und auch dass man so langsam in der
spätphase der pandemie auch ein bisschen
dem virus die tür aufmacht das ist also
schon infektion geben kann allerdings
war in diesem szenario nicht vorgesehen
dass wir jetzt so langsam eine sich
aufbauende sommer welle sehen und die
sollte uns schon sorgen machen auch weil
es eben mit einer unter- variante von
dem oregon virus verknüpft ist was auch
immun escape eigenschaften er hat das
heißt also auch menschen noch mal
infizieren kann die kurz vorher schon
einer omikron infektion hatten und all
das zusammengenommen und auch was
mögliche risiken sind für nicht nur das
individuum sondern auch für die gesamte
population beispielsweise auch die
entwicklung von longo witt verläufen und
auch doch eben anteilig schweren
verläufen das sollten wir im auge
behalten und deswegen schon uns gut
vorbereiten und ich finde es eigentlich
ein bisschen spät wenn wir erst im
september dann die nötigen beschlüsse
fassen finden die bundesländer übrigens
auch denn die müssen das ganze dann
umsetzen sodass
also bereits jetzt sich gedanken machen
sollte was für szenarien kommen und
diese einstellungen sap schon immer jot
jejange die die geht eben nur man in
einer pandemie nicht so gut sondern wir
müssen uns auch auf szenarien
vorbereiten und das in der tat durchaus
auf vorrat dass wir schnell reagieren
können und das macht eben die prävention
aus wenn wir wieder so agieren und wir
sind gut vorbereitet und habe das alles
gut im griff und so weiter und dann
handelt aber das virus eben anders und
lässt sich nicht aus der ruhe bringen
dann haben wir aber wenn jetzt richtig
verstehe die frage wer sind wir zu
sorglos würden sie dann mit ja
beantworten ja also wenn wir jetzt
wieder sehenden auges eine sich
aufbauende welle reingehen und einfach
mal abwarten was passiert dann ja es
gibt ja ein zusammenhang der diskussion
wie man auf die pandemie reagiert was
die richtige reaktion die richtige
verhaltensweise auch die richtige
gesetzliche regelung ist ein zauberwort
ich nenne sie mal hier bevor sie jemand
anders sagt eigenverantwortung
wie weit ist es denn mit unserer eigenen
verantwortung in dieser frage gestellt
also ich finde die eigenverantwortung
ist wichtig übrigens aber auch die
verhältnismäßigkeit das sagt schon
unsere verfassung die mag man darf nicht
mehr als unbedingt notwendig auch in die
freiheit der menschen eingreifen das ist
nicht irgendeine frage von geschmack
oder wohlwollen sondern ein
verfassungsgebot manche wie herr
kretschmann die haben offenbar ein
bisschen entzugserscheinungen vom
ausnahmezustand und ich mal sagen ich
leute nicht mit dem ausnahmezustand
sondern für uns freidemokraten ist ganz
wichtigen unterschied klar zu machen
zwischen der klugen und entschlossen und
pandemie bekämpfung einerseits die
brauchen wird die maßnahmen die
unbedingt nötig und auch nachweislich
wirksam sind und andererseits zu einer
gewöhnung an ein übermaß staatliche
eingriffe und das ist leider zu
beobachten bei einigen so eine
schleichende gewöhnung und ich finde die
länder tun übrigens gut daran einfach
ihre hausaufgaben zu machen es endet
niemand die ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten daran zum beispiel
für die schulen gerne an angemessenen
hygiene konzepten schon zu arbeiten für
den herbst und vieles mehr da kann ich
mich eher dran erinnern zb eine beginn
der pandemie dass da viele wochen
schulschliessungen waren und man hat die
zeit nicht genutzt um sich vorzubereiten
auf die zeit wenn die schule wieder
geöffnet werden können und so vieles was
jetzt verwaltungstrakt getan werden kann
kann man schon heute tun und ganz
entscheidendes übrigens das für den
blindflug beenden bei den daten auch da
können gerne die akteure in den ländern
und in den verwaltungen schon mal was
dafür tun dass wir zum beispiel zu den
tag genauen daten schneller kommen damit
wir das pandemie geschehen nicht immer
erst mit zeitverzögerung abbilden all
das kann man gerne tun aber gleichwohl
ist wichtig dass wir als gesetzgeber und
bundestag evidenzbasiert handeln und die
erkenntnisse ernst nehmen und abfahrten
also dass mit den daten dass hier die
den blindflug in sachen daten beenden
das hat ja was mit digitalisierung zu
tun dass prognostiziere ich mal wird
noch etwas dauern ganz kurz nach der
flirt mit dem ausnahmezustand das merke
ich mir diese bemerkung
verschneider eigenverantwortung wie kann
man hier nicht nur
die kann man nicht nur beanspruchen oder
da ist nicht nur bei euch mal muss sie
auch leben wird sie gelebt denn das
heißt ja auch ich könnte sie haben aber
gesagt die masken sei nicht so wichtig
zum beispiel in innenräumen wo es ein
bisschen kuschelig wird tatsächlich die
maske aufziehen das wäre ja auch eine
form der eigenverantwortung
wer also zwei dinge vielleicht erst
lernt eigenverantwortung ja nicht wenn
man nicht lernen muss also man kann
nicht irgendwie zwei jahre lang den
leuten alles entscheidung abnehmen und
dann sagen sowohl eigenverantwortung wir
sind immer menschen geben die sich nicht
verantwortlich verhalten wieder das
gegenüber noch anderen aber es kann halt
nicht sein dass alle anderen unter deren
geiselhaft an leiden und die sagt
übrigens nicht was man macht nichts
bringe ich bin sehr gespannt auf diesen
experten richtiggehend schwer davon aus
dass den innenräumen was bringen also im
sinne von wänden wirklich menschenmassen
zusammenkommen alles in ordnung aber
auch die aussage von menschen die das so
charakterisieren da ist doch nicht so
schlimm dann tragen eine maske also ich
weiß es nicht um die ohne dass irgendwo
mein gott maske ist so schlimm
kategorien zu rutschen ich möchte es
nicht machen wenn ich es nicht will und
deswegen höhe hätte ich gerne die
evidenz dafür dass was bringt und dann
würde ich mich daran halten aber das ist
eine regel dann wo wir daten dazu haben
und das ist übrigens das größte problem
wenn es zum beispiel herr lauterbach
sagt eine impfkampagne starten so finde
ich spannend er hat die impflücken
irgendwie gefunden ohne die daten dafür
zu haben wir wissen nicht wie viele
menschen genesen sind oder wäre es
eigentlich der impfte ist und also alles
sehr schwierig und solange das nicht hat
hat auch henrik strecke sagt dann würde
meine studie durchführen dafür und zu
sehen wo ist die im unglück
wir ansprechen und das vorher brauchen
wir über andere dinge reden wie wir sie
haben schon gesagt oder auch darauf
hingewiesen der sachverständigenrat der
bundesregierung wird ja ende des monats
eine bewertung der bisherigen krone
schutzmaßnahmen vorliegen
ich wage mal die prognose jede partei
würde genau das was lesen was zu ihren
inhaltlichen überzeugungen so richtig
gut passt kann man diesen dieses
ergebnis dieses gutachten dann wirklich
als blaupause für die diskussion im
herbst nehmen das gutachten was uns
erwartet wird nochmal ganz klare fakten
auf den tisch legen ich glaube aber auch
wir dürfen dieses gutachten nicht wir
dürfen nicht zu hohe erwartungen haben
ich glaube nicht dass fundamental neues
auf den tisch kommen wird denn einige
sachen wissen wir jetzt schon
bundesjustizminister schon der sagt er
ließ das durch und dann ist deine
entscheidung also das ist ja immer nicht
so an was da drin steht ist es absolut
richtig dass wir sagen wir warten dieses
gutachten ab und dann entscheiden ja das
ist richtig ich warne nur davor zu
denken dass da jetzt komplett andere
sachen raus kommen als das was wir schon
wissen und ein paar sachen gibt es da
und was wir schon wissen beispielsweise
ist das impfung grundsätzlich helfen
gegen einen schweren krankheitsverlauf
deshalb haben wir in dem sechs punkte
plan von herrn lauterbach drin dass wir
zum herbst noch mal eine impfkampagne
fahren wo wir noch mal informieren
aufklären und insbesondere auf die
gefährdeten gruppen noch mal zu gehen
und sagen das lager befürworter der
allgemeine impfpflicht ab 18 werden sie
das noch mal vorschlagen und vielleicht
versucht rautenberg für diese für diesen
vorschlag zu begeistern das thema
impfpflicht ist vom tisch was wir aber
in dem gesetzentwurf mit drin hatten und
da bin ich mir mit frau teuteberg
absolut einig ist dass wir die datenlage
verbessern müssen und wir hatten in
unserem gesetzentwurf drin dass wir
sagen wir machen eine digitale impf
datenerfassung und dann auch sagen zu
können wir wissen wer geimpft ist wer
nicht wie ein gewisser status ist und
dann auch individuell menschen
ansprechen zu können das ist nämlich ein
weg der in anderen europäischen ländern
beispielsweise in portugal zum erfolg
geführt hat und um beim thema daten zu
bleiben denn ich bin auch gleichzeitigen
digital
ausschuss da machen wir schon einiges
zusammen mit dem minister und mit dem
rkw beispielsweise wo wir auf der einen
seite schauen das bessere und
strukturierte daten aus den
krankenhäusern zudem bettenbelegung über
das system dem ist wo jetzt nach und
nach alle krankenhäuser angebunden
werden zentral zum lkw kommt das ist ein
baustein auf der anderen seite hat srk
ii ein sogenanntes syndrom xo waynes
eingeführt wo man auf verschiedenen
regen noch mal zusätzlich daten sammelt
über die arztpraxen über teilnehmende
krankenhäuser und über ein freiwilliges
system wird bürgerinnen und bürger in
deutschland daten spenden können und da
arbeiten wir dran schritt für schritt
die datenbasis zu verbessern und
maßnahmen viel zielgerichteter dann auch
umsetzen zu können kann ich so einfach
die unterschiede zwischen der teuteberg
und ihn herauszuarbeiten in dieser
sendung ich versuch's nachher dann
nochmal
herumreißt gibt ja immer wieder die
forderung von den ländern vor allen
dingen auch aus der opposition heraus
zum teil auch in der ampel das
infektionsschutzgesetz dass er im
september ausläuft doch weiterzuführen
möglicherweise sogar in einer kritischen
situation zu verschärfen fangen wir mal
die andere seite des
infektionsschutzgesetzes ab und diese
corona schutzmaßnahme die jetzt gerade
evaluiert werden welche übertreibungen
hat es denn da gegeben wo sind
schutzmaßnahmen der letzten zweieinhalb
jahren überzogen gewesen auch ansicht
eines wissenschaftlers
vielleicht wird es auch gar nicht so nur
auf übertreibungen reduzieren sondern
auch auf maßnahmen die absolut nicht
sinnvoll waren wie zb grenzschließungen
oder dass einzelne bundesländer
vorgeprescht sind und maßnahmen
durchgesetzt haben andere haben das
nicht gemacht und dann gab es dann so
schaukelbewegungen und auch die
mobilität der bevölkerung hat sich dann
da entsprechend angepasst also das sind
ganz viele dinge wo wir wirklich genau
analysieren müssen was ist
schiefgelaufen das machen wir ja schon
die ganze zeit und was wir aber eben
umgekehrt auch sagen können da kann man
es wirklich noch eine woche warten bis
dieses gutachten jetzt rauskommen wird
aber es ist ziemlich eindeutig klar was
zum tragen bringt etwas vor allen dingen
in innenräumen und eben von bringt auch
etwas und wenn man das jetzt
vielleicht nicht wartet bis die
sommerpause vorbei sondern bereits jetzt
die nötigen vorbereitungen dafür trifft
dann wäre das durchaus sinnvoll ich
wundere mich auch so ein bisschen warum
die impfkampagne erst im herbst starten
soll denn jetzt baut sich gerade eine
sommer welle auf und die wird nicht
einfach wieder auf null gehen und dann
kommt irgendwann schön zeitversetzt und
mit ausreichend zeit zur vorbereitung
die herbst welle und dann können wir ja
noch impfen das ist nicht so richtig
zielführend sondern man sollte jetzt auf
die leute zugehen mit verschiedenen
maßnahmen in der tat also direkt
ansprechen das impfangebot machen die
impfzentren stehen zum teil jetzt immer
noch leer um die könnte man jetzt gut
nutzen und dann vermeiden dass wir
wieder so ein peak bekommen von
nachfrage den markt zum beispiel hat
jetzt angeboten für alle die firma
impfung ab 50 das sind sachen die man
auch jetzt schon gut kommunizieren
vorwand für deutschland die für den
booster impfung jetzt und weil die ja
noch nicht der richtige impfstoff ist
für die neuen varianten man im herbst
eine fünfte das wäre durchaus denkbar
ganz genau dass ich wieder so viel
wochen und monate dazwischen dass das
dann durchaus einen sinn hat nochmal
nach zu ostern das immunsystem braucht
schon den abstand um dann noch mal
wieder aufgefrischt zu werden das ist
klar und in der tat eine nikon
spezifischer impfstoffe ist natürlich
prima wenn dann da auch ein erhöhter
eine erhöhte schutzwirkung auch
gegenüber den untervarianten zu erwarten
ist umgekehrt schützen aber auch die
bereits zugelassenen impfstoffe sehr
zuverlässig vor schweren verläufen und
mindern auch das risiko für einen long
kuwait verlauf
wir müssen lernen mit corona zu leben
hört man immer wieder das wird uns nicht
verlassen blöd ist das ja nur für den
lerneffekt bei denjenigen die die kurve
erkrankung nicht überleben machen wir es
uns dann manchmal auch zu leicht oder
ist das wirklich eine frage da sind sagt
gut das ist jetzt unser schicksal und
krone bleibt und dann müssen wir eben
wir können nicht ewige zeiten solche
artenschutzmaßnahmen solche
abwehrmaßnahmen in der gesellschaft die
schlichten hinaus also von dem was es
bedeutet mir sagen lang gelernt nicht
damit zu leben das wir für immer eben
abgeräumt sind und versuchen sie orbit
durchzuziehen was nicht funktioniert
wird wohl wieder sollen daten problem
wenn wir mit und ancona stirbt wissen
wir auch nicht wirklich wird das wird
übrigens das schwierigste
am unbedingt davon dass jeder tote einer
zu finden gab dass man alle einig aber
natürlich müssen wir mit dem virus leben
lernen also und wie schwer es
zurückkommt und da frage ich mich
wirklich besitzen in seinem hamsterrad
und habe weder die politik noch viele
deutsche irgendwo zu genannt müssen zwei
jahren weil eben als marco buschmann
eine woche aber eine letzte woche am
wochenende ja nur meint er würde das
kein abwarten was herauskommt und bei
der evaluierung das normalste der welt
um dann verhältnismäßig agieren zu
können hat einen schutzdamm geerntet und
gottes willen wieder diese fdp mit ihrer
freiheit und bindung ist das so und das
ist doch ein wahnsinn also das kann aber
immer so völker und gut jetzt
abstrahieren und hoffen dass twitter
nicht die welt ist und auch schon gar in
deutschland aber trotzdem dieser diese
wut und dieser da ist also dass ihr
nicht um die politik dieser vorprescht
es gibt offensichtlich einen großen teil
bevölkerung die sofort wieder leicht in
panik versetzt und da denken wenn es die
zahlen steigen und zwar nicht nur die
insolvenzen sondern auch vielleicht die
mobilisierungen und schweren verläufe
dass das sehr schnell wieder in dasselbe
muster befällt und demselben herbst
wieder finden und das bin ich eigentlich
wahnsinn in deutschland ist ein hoch
entwickeltes land gott sei dank also
marco buschmann sagt abwarten die mann
und frau teuteberg gesagt eigentlich
müsste schon mehr unternehmen zb im
kampagnen staaten für den herbst also
präventiv sein erinnert sich dass
minister spricht über gesetzgebung r
hindert niemanden daran dass das man in
seiner eigenen verantwortung dafür sorgt
dass die eigene schule behörde
pflegeeinrichtungen sich schon heute um
hygiene konzepte kümmert darum dass das
testen funktioniert und vieles mehr also
mir scheint diese pandemie ist zum einen
doch eigentlich das hat sich an vielen
stellen gezeigt auch im auch der
verfassungsschutz mich jetzt in
politikerin mit dem thema befasst bin
sagt das ist ja irgendwo auch eine
prüfung für unsere fähigkeit mit
ungewissheit mit komplexität umzugehen
gerade deshalb sind verschwörungs
erzählungen ja leider auch stark im
umlauf aber auch in der politischen
debatte gibt es noch diese sehnsucht
ständig zu vereinfachen und ständig
irgendwie von vorsicht oder
fahrlässigkeit als falschen alternativen
zu sprechen und so ist es doch nicht wir
müssen doch mit mit einer komplexen
situation verantwortungsvoll umgehen und
dazu gehört jetzt zum beispiel übrigens
das eigentlich mindestens genauso
wichtig wie manches was jetzt er überall
gefordert wird zum beispiel übrigens ist
auch dass die freiwillige griffel im
punkt zu forcieren das kommt eine
grippewelle auf und sind jetzt eher
viele menschen den letzten drei jahren
nicht mehr haben sich nicht mehr
immunisieren lassen gegen grippe die es
vielleicht sonst ohne die zusätzliche
corona pandemie getan hätten und für das
grundsätzliche wichtige ziel das wir zum
beispiel die intensiv intensiv
kapazitäten nicht überlasten im herbst
und im winter und tatsächlich todesfälle
vermeiden ist für viele menschen mit
risikoprofil er auch die grippeimpfung
jetzt eine sehr wichtige sache für all
das kann man gerne etwas tun daran
hindert einen niemand aber wir müssen
glaube ich eben aufpassen nicht
tatsächlich in so eine panik modus zu
kommen wo jetzt maßnahmen gefordert
werden deren zu wo zum teil deren
schaden offensichtlicher ist als dass
ihr nutzen schon bewiesen wäre und da
sollten wir einfach besonnen und
gleichzeitig entschlossen vorgehen wir
haben schon viele dinge manchmal sehr
schnell beschlossen wenn die
vorbereitung stimmt waren daten
erkenntnisse hat vernünftige anhörungen
gemacht hat und die endlösung und
parlament durchführen kann und das kann
man bei zwei sitzungswochen wo auch noch
mal eine woche dazwischen ist also da
kann man substanzielle sorgfältige
entscheidungen treffen und das sollten
wir auch tun die länder darf ich dazu
ganz kurz ein haken also das ist ja so
nicht ganz richtig denn bisher hat die
politik immer nur reagiert als die welle
schon sich aufgebaut hat dann wurden
erste maßnahmen getroffen aber in so
eine pandemie ist eigentlich nur gut
bekämpft war wenn man vorausschauend
plant und sich auf eventualitäten
einrichtet wir wissen eben nicht wie die
herbst welle werden würde es könnte gut
gehen und diese variante b a 5 die macht
halt nur leichte verläufe und auch nicht
so viele schwere alles in ordnung aber
es kann auch das szenario geben das ist
schwerer wird und wenn wir dann erst
aufwachen und sagen oh ist ja doch eine
schwerere verlauf dieser im herbst zu
erwarten denn pandemiewelle jetzt müssen
auch etwas tun dann sind wir nicht vor
der welle sondern dann ist die welle
schon da und das ist ja nur mal so mit
exponentiellen wachstum das geht dann
recht schnell und ich weiß nicht wie
schnell ihre sitzungswochen
entscheidungswege sind aber es ist hier
eben auch der bund die bundesebene
gefragt nicht nur die länder man kann
natur nicht alles schon dann sagen
sollen die mal machen aber wir haben ja
gelernt dass er auch gerade im rahmen
des infektionsschutzgesetzes hier
wichtige rahmen geben sein sollten das
wird ja jetzt wenn ich es richtig
verstanden habe vorbereitet ich bin
gespannt und durch hoffe das ist dann
auch schnell und eben vorausschauend
einsetzbar ist mir wirklich diese wenn
ich darauf eingehen darf diese
vorbereitung die läuft ja gerade ist es
nämlich so wie es meine kollegin
beschrieben hat wir sind jetzt schon in
einem sehr besonderen fakten basierten
arbeitsmodus und diese vorbereitenden
maßnahmen die sie fordern hat unser
minister letzte woche schon in
abstimmung mit seinen kolleginnen und
kollegen vorgelegt er ist aktiv dabei
die impfkampagne vorzubereiten er hat
entsprechend impfstoff eingekauft er ist
dabei die tests strategie zuhörten
überarbeiten diese stimmt er im übrigen
heute und morgen auf der laufenden
gesundheitsministerin kommt konferenz ab
mit den ländern damit auch die länder
mit dem bund an einem strang ziehen
sie doch nicht dumm stellen sie fordern
bestimmte dinge das auch in ordnung und
wir kennen ja auch unsere
ministerpräsident nur mit
ministerpräsidentin und dieser
aushandlungsprozess auch was kosten
angeht was aufgabenverteilung geht das
ist auch nichts neues das kennen wir
auch von anderen themen und das findet
heute und morgen auf dieser konferenz
statt und das ist gut so denn wir
brauchen diesen sieben punkte plan von
karl lauterbach der iss bereit wir sind
bereit für die verschiedenen szenarien
die uns auch der expertenbeirat
skizziert hat zu reagieren und das ist
absolut richtig nicht jetzt sofort mit
einem ganzen feuerwerk los zu schießen
sondern wir müssen die maßnahmen
vorbereiten um dann je nach szenario
adäquat reagieren zu können und das ist
der richtige weg ist bedeutet das für
das infektionsschutzgesetz das läuft ja
am 23 september ausfällt man das einfach
so inhaltlich fortschreiben es gibt ja
darüber auch diskussionen besteht die
befürchtung dass man dem
infektionsschutzgesetz die zähne zieht
wir haben dafür einen ganz klaren plan
und der lautet dass wir zum 30 juni ein
gutachten des sachverständigenrates
bekommen der uns noch mal ganz klar
daten und fakten basiert auf zeigen wird
welche maßnahmen wie wirken anschließend
werden sich die mitglieder der koalition
zusammen setzen das bewerten und einen
vorschlag machen wie das
infektionsschutzgesetz weiter entwickelt
da ist natürlich jetzt schon einig dann
ist ja karl lauterbach die leute gegeben
über diesen arbeitsmodus sind wir uns
absolut einig und ich finde es auch
ehrlich gesagt
professionelles so zu machen denn was
der expertenbeirat von uns auffordert
ist eine klare einheitliche
kommunikation der politik und dazu ist
es notwendig ein meinungsbildungsprozess
durchzuführen anhand von daten und
fakten die man möglichst auch nicht
wochenlang in der presse aus trägt
sondern sich zusammen setzt und einen
gemeinsamen vorschlag macht also das was
hierzulande ulrich beruhigt sie das naja
wenn ich von dieser vielen besonnenheit
gehöre dann kann ich ja ganz zufrieden
sein aber also ich wollte jetzt
tatsächlich auch gar nicht dass in frage
stellen sondern nur darauf hinweisen
dass wenn sie das so vorbereiten dass
sie dann ja wieder das habe ich auch
gerade selber gesagt dann reagieren auf
die entsprechenden szenarien aber die
bauen sich jetzt schon auf und wenn wir
verhindern wollen dass da noch weitere
opfer mit hinzu kommen und auch diese
long kurvenverläufe gehören mit dazu
finde ich dann sollte man eben jetzt in
dieser zeit behandeln und nicht erst
wenn wir wieder ganz viele hohe
neuinfizierten zahlen haben hohe
hospitalisierung traten todeszahlen ich
verstehe auch gar nicht wir haben pro
tag immer noch 100 menschen etwa die an
oder mit dem virus das ist eigentlich
auch gar nicht so erheblich verstärken
und das scheinen wir jetzt so als
kollateralschaden hinzunehmen und wir
haben über 500.000 menschen in
deutschland die an longo begleiten wenn
da nicht noch mehr dazu kommen wollen
müssen wir uns überlegen wie kann man
das verhindern und eben sinnvoll den
rahmen dafür schaffen auf bundesebene
und zusammen mit den ländern was soll
das konkret bedeuten meinen sie dass es
maßnahmen die jetzt nicht möglich sein
nach dem infektionsschutzgesetz vor dem
24 september konkret verhängt werden
müssen weil ansonsten haben wir die
möglichkeit wir haben in den zwei
sitzungswochen können wir das was in den
zwei monaten davor im gesamten juli
august in kenntnis des am 30 juni
vorgelegten berichtes dann vorbereitet
formuliert werden kann kann dann in zwei
vollen sitzungswochen mit noch mal einer
woche dazwischen zum nachdenken
beschlossen werden insofern werden ende
september die eventuell notwendigen
veränderungen in kraft seien deshalb
selbst wenn man ganz klar sagt es kann
da an oktober hatten willkommen dann
verstehe ich noch nicht ganz warum das
jetzt nicht überzeugend sein soll da
jetzt die gesetzgebung auf dieser basis
zu machen da hat das halten sie aber für
möglich sollte es bereits verheerende
zahlen im september geben das dann der
bundestag tatsächlich ein sehr viel
verschärfte ist ein schärferes
infektionsschutzgesetz dann
verabschiedet aufgrund der lage sein ja
wir müssen sehen was bis dahin passiert
wir haben diesen bericht des
sachverständigenrates und dann
entscheiden wir in den zwei tage ist ja
in welcher logik welche vorgehen also
ich kann mich noch erinnern an den
sommer 2020 war übrigens auch selbst
karl lauterbach im rückblick gesagt hat
er hat unterschätzt wie stark der
klimatische effekt der sommer jahreszeit
ist das dann doch an frischer luft das
kann vieles weniger gefährlich ist und
das in erheblichen einfluss hat auf das
infektionsgeschehen so ernst man
infektionsgefahren nimmt und vorbereitet
sein ist doch jetzt ein gewisser panik
modus darin wenn man so tut als müssten
im juli jetzt schon verschärfte
regelungen gelten und so tut als wäre
hier alles als wäre überhaupt nichts in
kraft und seien wir nicht handlungsfähig
also deshalb wir müssen einfach wirklich
aufpassen
das finde ich ständig so einen falschen
gegensatz aufmachen zwischen irgendwie
fahrlässigkeit oder maximaler
beschränkung auf vorrat das gibt es
einfach im rechtsstaat nicht jetzt ist
der versuch gescheitert diese evaluation
generell sozusagen ad absurdum zu führen
oder zu verschieben das wollte er unter
anderem herr drosten jetzt wird versucht
ihr ergebnis in frage zu stellen oder
vorwegzunehmen
halten wir uns einfach anders
beschlossene verfahren und gehen da
sorgfältig vor ich glaube das wird auch
der glaubwürdigkeit auch bei den
menschen die wir mitnehmen müssen bei
maßnahmen mehr nützen als irgendwelche
übereilten szenarien ich bin du musst
hier unterscheiden ich finde das ziel
weil sich gar nicht so widersprechen und
es geht in erster linie um sachen wie
beugen wir vor also welche maßnahmen
jetzt treffen die tun ja niemandem weh
lauterbach ist kampagne sofort startet
ja fantastisch betrifft
greift keine grundrechte ein genauso
eben was zum beispiel im fort sagen dass
eben pflegen was man da ist ohne rabl
gruppen schützen ein konzept das mehr
als master und die kann man sofort
machen bitte doppelt aber es geht ja
darum was dann im infektionsschutzgesetz
steht diese quasi die schnelle
eingreiftruppen das gesetz was macht man
wenn um gottes willen zu explodieren
gibt es daneben ausgangssperren locker
und blablabla deswegen findet diskussion
deswegen würden sie sich treffen bei dem
gesetz geht es darum wo ich wieder wie
stark kann man in die freiheiten eines
bürgers eingreifen weil wir mitten in
der monster panini stecken aber die
vorbereitung oder die vorbeuge die da
bin ich ganz behindern könnte man jetzt
machen und das ist doch absolut zwei
paar schuhe frage ist doch die wir haben
jetzt zweimal einen sommer erlebt und
anfang herbst und winter in dem man sagt
die menschen hätten im sommer aber schon
wesentlich mehr tun müssen präventiv tun
müssen dieses misstrauen gegenüber
politik die kommt ja nicht das kommt
nicht von irgendwo her also ist das
nicht auch ein problem auf das jetzt
gerade die ampel koalition die jetzt
geben die politische verantwortung hat
auch besser reagieren muss absolut denn
in der vergangenheit sind natürlich auch
fehler gemacht worden und wir sind in
einige wellen hineingestolpert und
mussten dann notfallmässig zum beispiel
mit schulschließungen reagieren wir
mussten damit reagieren weil das
geschäfte geschlossen wurden und das
sind aus meiner sicht fatale maßnahmen
für die es nur eine rechtfertigung gibt
wenn man gar keine anderen möglichkeiten
hat nur diese anderen möglichkeiten gibt
es mittlerweile wir sind mittlerweile
schlauer wir haben eine bessere
datenbasis und deshalb haben die
bürgerinnen und bürger zu recht ein
anrecht darauf dass wir uns besser
vorbereiten und besondere handeln und
genau deshalb machen wir unsere
hausaufgaben jetzt schon den test
konzepte impfkampagnen das können wir
jetzt waren das machen wir daten
aufbessern das tun wir und genau deshalb
bin ich der meinung sind wir jetzt
deutlich besser aufgestellt als vor den
letzten wellen und können darauf dann am
besten auch bessere antworten geben wie
heißt wird denn der korona herbst oder
winter was glauben sie halten sie dieses
szenario für denkbar heute morgen war
ich spiegel online zu lesen ist eine
gesundheitspolitiker der koalition hat
gesagt
wir müssen damit rechnen dass
möglicherweise 200.000 neuinfektionen am
tag incident ziehen weit über 1200 bis
300 tote am tag und eine über
sterblichkeitsrate von 5 bis 10 das ist
durchaus denkbar wollte seinen namen
nicht nennen wäre das war aber ist das
eine ein szenario das denkbar ist oder
wird da panik gemacht ja es ist denkbar
und es ist hat überhaupt nichts mit
panikmache zu tun das hat als diesen
gegensatz machen sie ja immer auf heute
werk das stimmt ja gar nicht sondern man
muss einfach nur jetzt mal sehen wie die
ganze sache sich gerade entwickelt und
wir haben einen sommer mit lockerungen
und die leute lassen auch das masken
tragen sein und so weiter und ist baut
sich im sommer trotz widriger
bedingungen für das corona virus und
seine verbreitung einen sommer welle auf
das heißt also da passiert etwas was in
den beiden songs vorher nicht passiert
ist das müssen wir genau beobachten ist
noch kein grund in panik zu verfallen
ganz im gegenteil aber wir müssen jetzt
darauf vorbereitet sein dass da
tatsächlich höhere zahlen kommt dass die
sommer welle eben nicht vorher abebbt
und dann irgendwann eine herbst/winter
welle kommen wird sondern dass das da
oben drauf gepackt wird und dann haben
wir ziemlich schnell wieder hohe zahlen
und das sind ganz klare modellierungs
möglichkeiten solche zahlen sind
durchaus realistisch ich erinnere nur
daran
spätsommer 20 und 21 wurde dann immer
gesagt wird nur ja also das sind ja so
hohe zahlen und zwei wochen später waren
die da also das heißt jetzt kann das
auch alles passieren und ich bewundere
ihre besonnenheit aber ich wollte und
wie gesagt nur zu bedenken geben so aus
epidemiologischer sicht dass das eben
auch recht schnell gehen kann und dass
wir vielleicht jetzt schon uns überlegen
sollten dass beispielsweise das masken
tragen im innenräumen in den
supermärkten usw durchaus jetzt schon
sinnvoll ist einfach um die infektions
die namik aus der sich aufbauenden
sommer werde so ein bisschen raus zu
leben das ist auch gut evaluiert und
abgesichert dass diese das masken tragen
wirkt und kann ein baustein sein hier
schonmal so etwas vorbeugend tätig zu
werden können die natürlich selber
machen klar aber noch besser wäre das
wenn das der bund mit den ländern
zusammen beschließen könnte jetzt
ein unglück kommt ja bekanntlich selten
allein wir haben ja neben möglicher
kroner pandemie
unsicherheiten jetzt im kommentar zum
winter noch andere
krisen ukraine
inflation
energiepolitik daraus abgeleitet wird
möglicherweise verfehlte
klimaschutzziele wenn jetzt zu einer
wirtschaftskrise auch noch eine corona
krise dazu käme mit all den ökonomischen
aspekten also geschäftsschließungen
gastronomie hotellerie zu kontakt
beschränkungen
können wir uns das zu einer
wirtschaftskrise auch noch leisten was
würde das bedeuten
neigen die zehner die krisen so zu
sortieren also es kann der ukraine
kriegen dann war corona vergessen sogar
umwelt da vergessen vor corona war in
wien nur umwelt also dieses des kühlers
mal wenn nicht mehr sehr parallel denken
können geht aber
nicht nur einander ab der handel müsse
eben ja genau und deswegen ist ja auch
irgendwie die partie gut beraten jetzt
in corona dingen ihre sachen auf die
reihe zu kriegen wo es noch möglich ist
so traurig das ist alles ein bisschen
kriegsmüde und zudem kann immer so gut
wir müssen jetzt ganz viel ukraine news
konsumieren deswegen sieht man dass
carola wieder wichtiger wird also man
sieht seinen medien sind ein perfekter
spiegel nur würde davor warnen bis
herbst eben zu warten um alles
vorzubereiten weil wenn dann wirklich
die energieprobleme kommen die menschen
hinten voran das geld fehlt und dann
noch leben schließen müssen wegen krone
gab das hat sehr viel soziales
unruhepotenzial
dass man sie sieht das möglicherweise
gibt es dann so eine
potenzierung von krisen was bedeutet das
dann auch für die für den krisen umgang
mit einer pandemie krise
das bedeutet dass wir an verschiedenen
fronten vorsorgen müssen wir haben jetzt
schon ausführlich darüber gesprochen wie
wir vorsorgen falls die nächsten corona
wellen kommen und wir müssen natürlich
auch vorsorgen wenn es darum geht
energie sicherheit in deutschland
herzustellen auch da ist die regierung
an verschiedenen stellen dabei zuschauen
wie bekommen wir die gesagt die
gasversorgung gesichert wo bekommen wir
flüssiggas her wie füllen wir die
speichert das ist der zweite baustein
der vorsorge wenn es um energie geht und
genau so müssen wir vor sorgen dass wir
gegen das wir für die inflation lösungen
finden insbesondere für die menschen die
wenig geld haben die von den hohen
preisen für lebensmittel für sprit
besonders hart getroffen sind dass wir
das abfedern und auch da ist die
regierung in konstruktiven austausch um
vorsorge zu betreiben damit wir eben
nicht eine potenzierung mit dieser krise
bekommen diese krisen am eines gemeinsam
die kosten eine menge geld hat der
bundesfinanzminister christian lindner
noch so viel in der kasse diese ganzen
krisen zu finanzieren weil die pandemie
krise ist ja auch teuer kurzarbeiter
geld zb
unterstützungen für unternehmen das war
ja er hat ja auch schon sehr viel
gekostet jetzt kommen die anderen krisen
und die ganzen anderen kosten dazu die
haben jedes kabel aufgezählt hat ist
dass da noch zu händeln der staat kann
auf dauer nicht mehr ausgeben als wir
auch erwirtschaften und insofern er muss
das auch eine ausnahme bleiben wo wir
wieder zu einer zu einer normalität
nämlich der der haushaltspolitischen
solidität zurückkehren
unter anderem genau die schuldenbremse
weil wir können wir können nur geld
ausgeben was vorher erwirtschaftet wurde
dass das fällt nicht vom himmel sondern
es muss von vorher auch von bürgerinnen
und bürgern erwirtschaftet werden und
durch steuern eingenommen werden
schulden sind ja sonst auch steuern von
morgen das muss uns klar sein und wenn
wir generationengerechtigkeit umfassend
verstehen und das betrifft die umwelt
und klimapolitik genauso wie die
finanzpolitik ist das keine option was
ich wichtig finde gerade weil wir so
eine art seriöses multitasking betreiben
müssen weil wir verschiedene probleme
wichtige herausforderungen gleichzeitig
angemessen
bewältigen müssen ist übrigens auch die
psychische gesundheit von menschen
wichtig und das auch mal da
widerstandsfähig bleibt die nerven sind
strapaziert es gibt viel auch sozusagen
an
psychischen problemen traurigkeit
angespannten nerven auch durch diese
besondere situation der pandemie auch
deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir eben
besonnen damit umgehen dass wir das
nötige tun aber auch darauf achten
dass das ist auch mal so ein bisschen
erholung jetzt von dieser situation gibt
immer verantwortungsvoll aber dass wir
darauf achten dass zum beispiel das dass
sich menschen an frischer luft im sommer
begegnen und auch mal was anderes sehen
und erleben ist auch wichtig gerade
damit wir durchhaltefähigkeit haben und
dann im herbst und winter sozusagen alle
die nerven aufbringen so woldt
notwendige regeln einzuhalten als auch
die anderen krisen zu bewältigen und und
jeder auch seine verantwortung an seinem
platz war nimmt auch das ist eine ganz
wichtige sache karl lauterbach hat der
ja im letzten herbst als er
bundesgesundheitsminister wurde ja das
war ja eigentlich fast eine
volksabstimmung die ihn zu in dieses amt
gehievt hat war ja so was wie der
sanitäter des landes sein image hat
gelitten er ist nicht mehr ganz so gut
in der öffentlichkeit angesehen und sich
das erklären wird geschieht ihm da
unrecht oder warum oder ist hatte
einfach sozusagen wird bezahlen müssen
an die zwänge eines amtes karl
lauterbach hat einen der absolut
schwierigsten jobs in dieser
bundesregierung und obwohl der job so
schwierig ist und von vielen
unwägbarkeiten
begleitet ist macht er einen guten job
und er hat auch weiterhin ein gutes bild
in der bevölkerung in summe und der
grund dafür ist ein ganz wesentlicher
denn karl lauterbach ist derjenige der
dafür steht dass fakten und daten
basiert gearbeitet wird karl lauterbach
war und ist derjenige der immer die
neuesten studien sich anguckt der
permanent mit internationalen und
nationalen expertinnen und experten im
austausch ist um jederzeit fakten und
daten basiert gute entscheidungen zu
treffen und das macht er aus meiner
sicht von anfang an richtig und ich
würde es sehr begrüßen wenn er diesen
arbeitsstil beibehält und jetzt auch
noch unterstützt von den kolleginnen und
kollegen der fdp das macht sinn den
kolleginnen und kollegen der fdp müssen
wir noch ganz kurz kommen sie haben sich
ja gegen ungerechtfertigte kritik an der
auch in der fdp politik verwahrt
rautenberg sie haben ein 89-jähriger
parteimitglied namens gerhard baum der
gelegentlich in der öffentlichkeit
äußert und der hat gesagt die
wahlniederlagen der fdp im frühjahr bei
den drei landtagswahlen
die hätten ihre wesentliche ursache auch
in populismus und der
verantwortungslosigkeit in sachen corona
das kommt ja wie gesagt aus der eigenen
partei
gerhart baum äußert sich zu viel in der
politik
was sagen sie zu diesem vorwurf das ist
seine persönliche meinung erstens würde
ich sowieso ganz unabhängig ob man die
teilt oder nicht corona politik nicht
nicht danach machen wie sie ankommt und
irgendwie aufgebracht aber dass man da
ganz schön erschreckend diese
wahlergebnisse jahr wollte sie sind ja
ernst zu nehmen aber das hat weniger mit
den einlassungen von gerhart baum zu tun
und wenn er seine eigene logik da ernst
nimmt dann hätte er in der innenpolitik
zu ganz anderen maßnahmen kommen müssen
also mir scheint das da er die
persönliche situation seine meinung zur
corona mehr beeinflusst als die
sorgfältige prüfung anhand der
verfassungs maßstäbe die für liberale
aus guten gründen ansonsten ja auch gilt
die gilt für mich in allen
politikbereichen dass die freiheit nicht
begründungspflicht ich ist sondern der
eingriff in die freiheit und das wäre
eine verhältnismäßigkeitsprüfung
stattfinden lassen und da würde ich mir
wünschen dass jeder und jede ganz
unabhängig vom eigenen fachbereich oder
von der persönlichen lebenssituation
dazu steht dass wir diese diese
rechtsstaatlichen argumentation standard
konsequent anwenden und dann glaube ich
gibt es viele andere erklärungen aber
das ist mir ein bisschen zu einfach so
schnell habe ich das richtig im kopf das
hat warum das in einer publikation der
weltgruppe veröffentlicht hat und sie
damit herausgefordert
jede handschuhe aufgenommen er schrieb
es so vom amputierten
freiheitsverständnis der fdp war
fantastisch und die haben dann so quasi
rhetorisch gefragt ob sie nicht in der
falschen partei fühlt weil er ein
fantastischer grüner er hat das werde
ich mich erinnern also 82 haben dass
auch manche gefragt nachdem die
sozial-liberale koalition es bei allem
bei aller ernsthaftigkeit und wir
beschäftigen uns mit diesen
wahlergebnissen die sind ungefähr auf
dem niveau wie in der aktiven zeit von
herrn baum in einem drei parteien system
und jetzt sind sie in einem sechs
parteien system also manchmal muss man
auch ein bisschen die dinge ins
verhältnis setzen
kann die impfquote noch gesteigert
werden herr ulrich wir liegen weil also
wir haben ja darüber gesprochen dass ich
das ja nicht genau eruieren lässt werke
es gibt auch eine duplizität andere da
etwas oder tappen etwas im dunkeln
liegt bei und knapp unter 80 prozent so
etwa genau aber es gibt länder die haben
90 95 prozent lässt sich das dahin noch
steigern oder müssen wir schon mal
abziehen die sich als corona in diesem
jahr das ist ja leider so dass wir da
eine ziemlich hohe gruppe haben eine
ziemlich große gruppe in deutschland wir
müssen in der tat mit haben ja die das
thema kommunikation schon angesprochen
also das besser kommunizieren und das
ist wirklich sehr misslich dass wir das
instrument in händen haben hier gut
vorsorgen zu können mit mit impfungen
das risiko stark zu senken dass wir
überhaupt noch mal diese großen
maßnahmen im herbst und winter auspacken
müssen indem einfach sich mehr menschen
impfen lassen und dass man dann auch
kommunikation verbessert werden durch in
kampagnen gab es ja jedes kampagnen gab
es und auch dass man wirklich auch
gezielt auf menschen zugegangen ist das
gab und gibt es ja auch das ist ganz
wichtig und darüber hinaus auch
natürlich wirklich die argumente der
impfgegner
aufnehmen und die gegenargumente gut und
überzeugend vorbringen das ist auch ganz
wichtig dass man das nicht einfach
unwidersprochen stehen lässt und
insgesamt muss man eben tatsächlich auch
parteiübergreifend am besten das konzept
der des impfens nämlich dass man
präventiv etwas angeht was man sonst
reaktiv mit viel viel mehr aufwand nur
beherrschen könnte das konzept mal
grundsätzlich vermitteln und das gilt
auch für so etwas wie masken tragen
jetzt bei einer sich aufbauen sommer
welle das heißt um viel arbeit sich zu
sparen wenn die große pandemiewelle im
herbst winter kommen wird sollte man
jetzt eben mit relativ wenig aufwand
etwas bewirken und dann wäre das mit der
impfkampagne auch jetzt schon eigentlich
nicht an sinnvolle maßnahme würde das
gespräch gerne noch weiter führen aber
wir sind am ende der sendung ich bedanke
mich bei den datenberg bei einer
schneider bei matthias mädels und bei
timo ulrichs liebe zuschauer morgen in
der phoenix runde gipfel in brüssel soll
die ukraine in die eu
jetzt folgt phoenix der tag mit mayer
weber da geht es um das gleiche thema
das wir morgen genauer behandelt werden
nämlich eine regierungserklärung des
bundeskanzlers zum bevorstehenden gipfel
morgen in brüssel wie gesagt welches
thema aufnahme der ukraine wann
kandidatenstatus gleich wir werden sehen
bleiben sie bei uns